authorities in Paris may have caught a
lucky break in the investigation but we
begin in New York where Kim and Kanye
remain behind a fortress of security
Kanye West rushed to his car and he did
not look happy he left Kim side last
night their first time apart since they
returned together from the airport
following Kim's Paris robbery a source
tells ET Kim and Kanye are reassessing
their security detail yesterday workers
set up barricades to keep the press and
the public back from their Tribeca
apartment we're told the couple also
plans on adding undercover security
guards it's been three days now since
Kim was robbed at gunpoint in this Paris
apartment and there is a possible new
lead in the investigation an eyewitness
tells ET police recovered security
camera footage from this nail salon that
showed images of the mass robbers
running by also a source tells ET kim
spoke on the phone with French police
yesterday giving them an extensive
interview I'm told she's talked a lot
about the key witness in the heist the
hotel concierge and the bizarre
experience that they shared my source
says Kim told police the concierge was
present and handcuffed for the entire
incident and he remained calm throughout
she actually talked to him during the
ordeal asking him if they were going to
die to which he responded he didn't know
meanwhile Kim just got blasted for being
too flashy on social media because that
famous and you put all your jewelry on
that you go to hotels they
can come here to the room famed designer
Karl Lagerfeld criticized the reality
star during paris fashion week I don't
understand why she was in a hotel with
no security in England you cannot
dissipate your wealth and then be
surprised that some people want to share
well in light of the robbery the
Kardashians maybe reexamining their
social media strategy as of this morning
Caitlyn Jenner was the only family
member to comment on the robbery she
posted a picture of cam and wrote quote
after hearing the full story I'm so
thankful she's okay it's a reminder for
us all to be careful in the uncertainty
of this world
you